DONALD TRUMP.
>> Dan: GREG, THANKS A LOT.
I APPRECIATE IT, THANKS FOR YOUR
INSIGHT.
THE WHICH HEARTENED AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP CONTINUES.
HUNTER BIDEN CONTINUES TO CASH
IN ON HIS LAST NAME.
UNDER USE THE TRAPPINGS OF HIS
VICE PRESIDENCY TO PURSUE
LUCRATIVE BUSINESS DEALS WITH
MEXICAN BILLIONAIRES.
I'M GETTING TO LOSE TRACK OF THE
MILLIONAIRES.
DESPITE JOE'S PROMINENCE THAT HE
NEVER SPOKE TO HIS SON ABOUT HIS
FOREIGN DEALS, PHOTOS FROM THE
DAILY MAIL SHOW JOE AND HUNTER
ALONGSIDE HUNTER'S
LATIN AMERICAN BUSINESS
PARTNERS, THERE IT IS.
I CAN SEE THAT ON THE RETURN.
THERE IT IS, RIGHT THERE, IT'S
PHOTOS, IT'S CALLED EVIDENCE,
FOLKS.
WE HAVE A NAME FOR THAT, IT'S
CALLED EVIDENCE.
IT TAKE A LOOK ON THE SCREEN,
YOU WANT TO INVESTIGATE THAT?
OR DO WE HAVE TO DO ALL OF YOUR
HOME LOOK FOR YOU A YEAR LATER
HUNTER FLEW TO MEXICO THIS CITY
WITH HIS DAD WHERE HE ATTENDED
BUSINESS GREETINGS.
REALLY JUST THE STORY ANNOYS ME.
HUNTER'S TAXES ARE UNDER
INVESTIGATION BY THE FEDS.
ANY CHANCE HE WILL BE HELD TO
THE SAME STANDARD OF THE TRUMP
ORGANIZATION?
[LAUGHS]
HILARIOUS.
YOU KNOW WITH MORE DETAILS
MIRANDA DEVINE AND
"NEW YORK POST" COLUMNIST JASON
JASON PARE AT A THANKS FOR
JOINING US.
MIRANDA, I WILL GO TO YOU FIRST.
HUNTER BIDEN, THE MOST
FRUSTRATING ABOUT THE ENTIRE
THING IS THE WHOLE LAPTOP
FIASCO.
WHEN THE FBI TOOK THE LAPTOP, WE
HAD THE FBI CASE NUMBER.
IT WAS A REPORTED SEVEN OR EIGHT
MONTHS AGO, I DON'T KNOW HOW
LONG AGO.
WE HAD THE CASE NUMBER.
ALL THE MEDIA HAD TO DO WAS CALL
THE FBI AND SAY, BEFORE THE
ELECTION SAY, IS A REAL CASE
AGAINST THE SKY?
WE HAVE THIS WHOLE CASE NUMBER
THING.
IF THEY DID NONE OF IT.
>> THE FBI HAS HAD THE LAPTOP
SINCE DECEMBER 2019.
I DON'T THINK THEY WOULD'VE TOLD
ANYONE IN THE MEDIA THEY HAD
CALLED AND ASKED ABOUT IT.
THEY KEEP THAT VERY CLOSE TO
THEIR CHEST.
LET'S JUST HOPE THAT THEY ARE
INVESTIGATING IT.
"THE NEW YORK POST" BROKE THE
STORY IN OCTOBER.
WE'VE RUN NOW TO GO PHOTOGRAPHS,
WHEN THIS WEEK OF THE MEXICAN
BILLIONAIRES HAVING BREAKFAST
WITH THE JOE BIDEN AND HUNTER
BIDEN AND THE VICE PRESIDENT'S
RESIDENCE IN 2015, AND A COUPLE
OF WEEKS AGO WE RAN ANOTHER
PHOTOGRAPH AND ANOTHER STORY
ABOUT HOW JOE BIDEN HAD SHOWED
UP AT A DINNER THAT HUNTER BIDEN
WAS HOLDING AT CAFE MILANO IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., IN APRIL 2015
FOR BUSINESS PARTNERS FROM
VARIOUS COUNTRIES, SUCH AS THE
UKRAINE, RUSSIA, KAZAKHSTAN, AND
MEXICO.
OUR STORY THIS WEEK, TODAY, AND
YESTERDAY, IS ABOUT THOSE
MEXICAN BILLIONAIRES WHO HUNTER
AND HIS UNCLE, JOE'S BROTHER,
YOUNGER BROTHER, WERE VERY
INTERESTED IN PILING THEIR CASH
INTO THEIR OWN POCKETS.
THIS IS TYPICAL OF JOE BIDEN WHO
PRETENDED DURING THE ELECTION
CAMPAIGN THAT HE KNEW ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING ABOUT HUNTER BIDEN'S
BUSINESS AFFAIRS OVERSEAS.
HE SAID THAT REPEATEDLY.
HE'S NOW BEING SHOWN OVER AND
OVER, AND THERE'S MORE EVIDENCE
ON THE LAPTOPS STILL TO COME
THAT HE WAS INTIMATELY INVOLVED.
HE USED THE PERKS OF HIS OFFICE
TO HELP HUNTER AND HIS BROTHER,
JIM BIDEN SHAKEN MONEY USING HIS
INFLUENCE FROM COUNTRIES AND
OLIGARCHS AND BILLIONAIRES
OVERSEAS.
>> Dan: JASON, LISTEN, THE
SERGEANT SALTS MEDIA, I DON'T
KNOW THING, I DON'T SEE NOTHING.
WE HAVE PICTURES OF JOE BIDEN.
WE HAVE PHOTOS OF HIM WITH
HUNTER'S BUSINESS PARTNERS.
WE HAVE EMAILS, LITERAL NOT
FIGURATIVE, LITERAL EMAILS FROM
HUNTER BIDEN FROM HIS LAPTOP
SAYING, THANKS FOR LETTING US
MEET YOUR DAD LAST NIGHT.
WE HAVE THE BUSINESS PARTNER
LIKE, JOE BIDEN KNEW THE WHOLE
TIME.
IN THE MEDIA SITE, HERE, I DON'T
SEE NOTHING.
WHAT'S GOING ON?
THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
SPEAK OF LACK OF INTELLECTUAL
TRIESTE BY THE MEDIA IS
DISCUSSING PAIRED WHEN JOB BIDEN
SAYS HE'S NEVER TALKED TO HIS
SON ABOUT HIS BUSINESS DEALINGS,
THAT'S FLAT OUT LIE.
WHEN JOE BIDEN SAID HE DIDN'T DO
ANYTHING, THAT'S A LIE.
HE CALLED HUNTER BIDEN THE
SMARTEST PERSON ON THE PLANET.
HUNTER BIDEN HAS HAD PROBLEMS
WITH DRUGS, GUNS, RUSSIAN, HE'S
TAKEN SUPPOSEDLY $3.5 MILLION
FROM THE EX-MAYOR OF MOSCOW.
HE HAS DEALS IN THE UKRAINE,
CHINA, FLYING ON AIR FORCE TO
USING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE'S
ACCESS, AIR FORCE TWO TO GO HAVE
THESE MEETINGS.
IT DAD LYING ABOUT IT, NO HE
SAYS, I'M GOING TO GET INTO THE
ARTS BUSINESS, AND YOU'RE GOING
TO PAY ME $500,000 FOR MY PIECE
OF ART.
LIKE I SHOULD BE IN JAIL, HE
SHOULD BE INVESTIGATED, HE
SHOULD BE ON THE COVER OF "TIME"
MAGAZINE, HE'S THE ONE WHO
SHOULD BE DOING THE PERP WALK.
>> Dan: I GOT ABOUT A MINUTE
LEFT.
IT DON'T KNOWS THIS CASE BETTER
THAN YOU, ESPECIALLY THE LAPTOP.
I KNOW YOU GOT MATERIAL COMING
OUT ABOUT THAT SOON.
DO THINK THERE WILL BE ANY
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THIS GUY?
IS THIS JUST GOING TO BE ONE OF
THESE MoveOn.org THINGS?
WHERE THEY LIKE, YEAH,
YESTERDAY'S NEWS?
>> WE WILL SEE.
MY BOOK "LAPTOP FROM
"WILL BE COMING OUT IN A COUPLE
OF MONTHS.
WE'LL BE RUNNING STORIES IN
"THE NEW YORK POST" IN BETWEEN.
I THINK IT'S REALLY OUT OF MY
HANDS WHETHER OR NOT THE
AUTHORITIES ARE INVESTIGATING.
WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE SOME TAX
INVESTIGATIONS GOING ON, AND I
THINK MONEY LAUNDERING IS
ANOTHER ALLEGATION THAT'S GOING
ON, FEDERAL INVESTIGATIONS INTO
HUNTER BIDEN.
LET'S SEE WHAT HAPPENS WITH
THOSE.
AS FOR THE REST OF THE MEDIA, I
THINK IT'S REALLY ON THEIR OWN
CONSCIENCE.
THE MATERIAL WILL BE OUT THERE
FOR THE PUBLIC TO MAKE THEIR OWN
JUDGMENT AND FOR HISTORY TO
RECORD.
>> Dan: I HAVE NO FAITH IN